vuelta atrás después del alboroto por
las acusaciones de intentar influir en
las elecciones de 2020 la oficina de
correos de eeuu ha revocado los
polémicos cambios que estos
manifestantes de atlanta reclaman que
podrían dificultar la votación por
correo
nuestro derecho a votar por correo está
siendo atacado y estamos en medio de una
pandemia
ha habido un feroz debate sobre la
financiación postal en eeuu con un
número récord de estadounidenses que
esperan votar por correo debido al cob y
19 los últimos meses el servicio postal
del país comenzó a aplicar lo que han
denominado medidas de reducción de
costos incluyendo la eliminación de
buzones la cancelación de entregas y el
cierre de centros de clasificación pero
el martes el director general de correos
lewis de joe anunció que los cambios han
sido suspendidos hasta después de las
elecciones de noviembre para evitar
incluso la aparición de cualquier
impacto en el correo electoral el
movimiento viene después de una protesta
de los demócratas y una advertencia de
20 estados que se preparaban para
demandar a pesar del giro de 180 grados
la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi sigue
adelante con la votación para evitar
cambios en el correo postal en el año
electoral
quieren detener esto porque eliminar los
obstáculos de participación de la
votación y tienen miedo del votante
miedo del pueblo americano porque porque
la gente está sobre ellos
donald trump ha afirmado repetidamente
sin pruebas que un aumento de los votos
por correo conduciría a un mayor fraude
el voto por correo está muy extendido
entre los estadounidenses incluyendo al
propio mandatario que votó por correo en
las primarias de marzo y en las
elecciones intermedias de 2018